Sterling is the most disrespected player
okay in English History you going to
disrespect him now I'm not I'm biging
him up I'm giving him his flowers at
times where England have needed a spark
at times where England have needed goals
yeah he's always overlooked I remember
in the Euros where's Jack GIS why is
Jack Gish not starting Sterling when
Kane wasn't doing anything when Gish was
on the bench he single-handedly got us
through the group stages into the into
the Knockouts and then he scored again
in The Knockouts as well completely
massive player for England Frank Lampard
part of the failed Midfield fraternity
that you spoke about where does he fit
in what does he do at Club level cool
but for England an impact for England
powerful it is Raheem Sterling are you
going to put him in of course I am what
yeah now laughing now but I'm glad I'm
actually glad he's on this Bard because
honestly I think Raheem Sterling gets
disrespected all the time for England
was fantastic